two major stories out of china today
that government now introducing a new
wave of lockdowns a coveted variant has
taken hold in cities
including the 11 million populated town
of wuhan
officials there reporting less than two
dozen cases so far but there are others
in other parts of the country
michael pillsbury hudson institute
director of chinese strategy
and the author of the 100 year marathon
it is great to have you back and
good morning to you thank you for your
time i want to get to this new story
about a nuclear program in a moment but
first what do you think we can report
about the various cases of cobit popping
up in china
well bill for 18 months now we've had a
breakdown in u.s china cooperation
in tracking the virus and analyzing the
various samples
ever since president trump's phone call
in january last year the xi jinping
resulted in she's saying no i don't want
any american scientists coming here
so it's very hard for us to verify or
corroborate any of the stories that are
coming out
worst case is that china really is
deeply involved in this and they know
about it
and they're deliberately lying best case
is it was a mistake
president trump tried to help them he
said about february of last year
this could have been a mistake in the
lab he's trying to open a way for xi
jinping to get out of this cover-up
but the chinese would not take the hint
they're still uh
on their original propaganda line that
this may have come from america
it didn't even come from china that's
quite a whopper to believe in fact this
is what china says about this
there was a house republicans put out
the report about the origins of kovid
um suggesting uh that very thing and
this is what chinese
foreign ministry said the relevant
report totally based on the concocted
lies and distorted facts without
providing any evidence is not credible
or scientific
this february a china who joint expert
team visited the wuhan
institute of virology members of the
joint expert team spoke highly
of the institute's openness and
transparency and reached a major
conclusion the joint study report that
the allegation of lab leaking is
extremely unlikely
so that you know they hang their hat on
that
ex you know that expertise right
yeah i don't agree with the chinese
spokesman i think the mccall reported as
we call it congressman
mike mccall of texas his report was not
based on
lies or made up he assembled a lot of
the available evidence
and showed that it's plausible he
couldn't prove it 100 but it's plausible
this came from a lab
and could have been either a mistake or
something more sinister
so but they dismiss anything like this
uh the problem is on our side dana
uh dr fauji and his team at nah
need to provide a chronology so-called
tick-tock of what exactly they've been
doing over the last five years with this
wuhan laboratory
apparently there's a lot more to be
revealed from the american side that's
what concerns me we shouldn't be
imitating the chinese silence approach
dr fauci should probably
have a fairly serious press conference
and explain what happened
that country has 144 medium and
high-risk areas the most since
the outbreak in i guess late 2019.
it's described as the delta variant but
who knows right i mean it could be a
different variant we'll see whether or
not that's the case
another big story here a nuclear program
has been detected a second site has been
located what do you think we're learning
about this
primarily in western china
well this is another example of
something the chinese have jumped
to rebut and make fun of and say that
this approximately 250
holes in the ground with kind of a metal
tint on top
the chinese say this is wind turbine
construction
and nobody should be worried our own
government hasn't taken an authoritative
position yet
but the implication is they could be
doubling or tripling the number of
h-bombs they have targeted on american
cities now we don't have
missile defense against chinese icbms we
carefully limit our missile defense to
just iran and north korea
we would have to start a really major
program to enhance our missile defense
if these chinese icbm silos really are
real icbm silos
i'm kind of worried about it frankly
yeah i mean that does seem like
it is worrisome right and then to your
point that we don't have
um the the defense just last question
for you so
october 31st i believe is when joe biden
and uh the rest of the g20 allies
our allies and china will be together do
you think that president biden ought to
have
some sort of a strategy going into that
meeting to deal with this very thing
well i've expected more out of the biden
administration they
they said a lot of harsh things about
china when they first came in
uh joe biden himself said that china was
not going to surpass america on his
watch
the very same thing dana that president
trump used to say but so far they have
not outlined
a real strategy that goes point by point
how to counter china
they seem to put everything in terms of
allies and partners that somehow the
japanese and indians are going to come
to our aid and i don't see much evidence
of that so far
these other countries are probably more
intimidated by china than we are so i
expect more from the by the
administration about their strategy
thank you yeah please come back we'll
talk more about that great to have you